je
corte au coeur de la corse un nid
d'aigle c'est ici que tout commence le 9
mai 1769 aponte nouveau les soldats de
louis quins taille en pièces les hommes
de paoli cela en est fini des rêves
d'indépendance
la france qui a acheté l'île aux génois
et désormais chez elle paoli abandonne
corte et s'enfuit en angleterre
ceux qui l'ont soutenu prennent le
maquis les bonaparte et charles et
laetitia sa jeune épouse sont du nombre
il quitte cette vieille maison de corte
où est né joseph futur roi de naples et
d'espagne est ou a été conçue napoléon
ils vont se réfugier dans la montagne au
dessus de corte
à 19 ans laëtitia est enceinte de six
mois elle attend napoléon plus tard elle
dira que durant tout cet héroïque et
douloureuse retraite
l'enfant s'agiter violemment des
semaines d'errance qui font basculer
charles dans le camp des vainqueurs les
buonaparte et se rallie aux français il
était temps laëtitia dans le terme
approche peut rentrer dans sa maison
d'ajaccio d'origine italienne les
bonaparte et se sont installés ajaccio
15e siècle aujourd'hui le souvenir du
plus illustre d'entre eux marc david son
empreinte rue bonaparte avenue du
premier consul cours napoléon place
d'austerlitz ajaccio s'est donné corps
et âme aux grands hommes à l'ouest de la
cité la place du général de gaulle
inauguré en 1802 et baptisée alors place
bonaparte
entouré de ses quatre frères napoléon en
costume d'empereur romain semble veiller
sur sa ville natale
adossé au vieux quartiers et faisant
face à la mer la cathédrale notre dame
de la miséricorde resterait récemment
l'édifice a retrouvé ses couleurs vives
originel le 15 août 1769 laetitia
assiste à la grand-messe prises des
premières douleurs elle a juste le temps
de rentrer chez elle elle accouche d'un
fils que l'on prénomme napoléon
il sera baptisé sur ses fonds de marbre
blanc
c'est rue saint-charles anciennement rue
malherbe a que se trouve la maison
bonaparte
c'est à peu près celle que napoléon a
connu dans son enfance
c'est aujourd'hui un musée on a vécu
derrière cette façade
dans le tumulte de l'enfance elisa
lucien louis caroline pauline et jérôme
régulièrement la famille bonaparte
s'agrandissait charles et lætitia
étaient des parents comblés
c'est ici dans cette pièce que napoléon
est venu au monde
il faut traverser cette longue galerie
pour accéder à la chambre dit à la
trappe
au pied de la commode cette fameuse
trappe par laquelle napoléon aurait
échappé aux pauliste qui voulaient
l'assassiner
laetitia éleva ses enfants avec beaucoup
d'amour mais d'une manne fer devenu sous
l' empire
madame mère est raconté en riant que
personne au monde l'avait giflée temps
de futurs roi et reine n'a boulho c'est
ainsi que l'on appelait napoléon enfants
s'isolait souvent dans cette grotte une
légende sur laquelle veille la
silhouette familière de l'empereur petit
chapeau et redingote grise on a
l'impression que les montagnes se sont
brisés exprès pour lui faire un cadre à
sa mesure
à quelques kilomètres d'ajaccio les îles
sanguinaires
on y arrive par une route qui épouse
toutes les sinuosités de la côte
cette promenade napoléon la fille
souvent avec joseph son frère aîné au
temps des premiers congés d'officier sur
le chemin on passe devant la chapelle
des grecs dans ses mémoires joseph écrit
no promenade journalière avec napoléon
se prolongeaient sur le rivage de la mer
bien au delà de la chapelle des grecs en
côtoyant un golf aussi beau que celui de
naples dans un pays embaumé par les
exhalaisons des myrtes et des orangers
nous ne rentrions quelquefois qu'à la
nuit close
dominant ajaccio caché dans une mère
d'olivier les minnelli la maison de
campagne des bonaparte
l'endroit n'a pas changé un lieu qui a
toujours charmé napoléon
son dernier séjour ici date d'octobre
il revenait d'égypte sa dernière escale
en corse
il y à bien longtemps qu'ajaccio n'est
plus simple de remparts seul subsiste la
citadelle qui est aujourd'hui encore
sous l'autorité militaire
mais revenons au mois de juillet 1790 le
vent de la révolution souffle sur la
france et une nouvelle fait le tour de
l'île
paoli est de retour babeau comme on
appelle le vieux dictateur corse rentrer
au pays avec une ambition secrète
l'indépendance de l'île bonaparte jeune
fille si d'artillerie fidèle à son rêve
d'autonomie corse ne peut être que
séduit ici au 44 de la rue fesch en
janvier 91 bonaparte s'enflamme contre
le député bussa focaux accusé de trahir
les patriotes corses mais paoli se méfie
chaque jour un peu plus des bonaparte
napoléon loyal à la france n'accepte
plus les dérives du vieux chef corse en
mai 93
poursuivi par les paulistes il trouvera
asile dans cette maison au 28 de la rue
fesch un mois avant à paris la
convention a décidé l'arrestation de
paoli toute l'île est en émoi
l'histoire s'est aussi attardé rue
bonaparte en septembre 1815
alors que l'empereur bug vers sainte
hélène murat arrive à ajaccio il les
passera six jours le temps de rassembler
une poignée d'hommes pour repartir à la
conquête son trône de naples
il habitait cette maison une expédition
que murat paya de sa vie c'est le
cardinal fesch l'oncle maternel de
napoléon qui a entrepris la construction
de ce palais il abrite aujourd'hui une
partie des seize mille tableaux
rassemblés par le cardinal
dans l'ailé droite la chapelle impériale
élevé sur les ordres de napoléon iii
les parents de napoléon son oncle flèche
et sept autres membres de la famille
dorment dans le caveau de la chapelle
impériale
en cercle et de figuiers de barbarie
la tour de capitol haut se dresse
fièrement face à ajaccio on raconte que
bonaparte s'y réfugia trois jours au
printemps 1793 lors des affrontements
entre les postes et les français c'est
en tout cas au pied de la tour qu'il
embarque sa mère et ses jeunes frères et
soeurs poursuivi par les pas aux listes
leur maison d'ajaccio a été pillée et
saccagée défiant l'horizon cette
forteresse qui domine la mer du haut de
ses falaises blanches c'est bonifacio en
février 1793 quelques semaines avant la
rupture avec paoli bonaparte occupe
cette maison lieutenante colonelle en
second du bataillon des volontaires
corse
il a pour mission d'investir la petite
île de la maddalena puis d'attaquer la
sardaigne
l'expédition tournera court torpillé en
sous main par paoli autre visiteur
illustre
charles quint qui en 1541 de retour
d'afrique
le jas juste en face de la maison où
vécut bonaparte
au début du mois de juin 1793
c'est un homme traqué qui bravant mille
dangers kit ajaccio à cheval pour calvi
à
il retrouve les siens chez son parrain
dans cette maison à sainte hélène il se
souviendra de ceux qui l'ont aidé à
échapper aux palistes son testament en
fait foi le 11 juin 1793 napoléon et sa
famille s'embarquait pour toulon six
mois après il reprenait la ville aux
anglais l'aigle avait pris son envol
le 3 mai 1814 le temps est radieux une
faible brise pouces une frégate battant
pavillon anglais vers portoferraio à son
bord l'empereur napoléon que l'europe a
fait roi de l'île d'elbe une île qui
appartenait alors à la france
à terre la surprise fait place à l'
enthousiasme dans l'exaltation on se
prépare à accueillir le nouveau s'ouvre
le 4 mai sitôt le jour lever la foule se
presse sur le port envahi le toit des
maisons
tous veulent la percevoir à midi le
canon tonne les cloches des chaînes
l'empereur en habit vert des chasseurs
de lagarde arrive à portoferraio sa
capitale il entre en ville en passant
sous la voûte de la porte de mer la
piazza della repubblica
ir la place d'armes a été prise d'assaut
par les et le bois et c'est aux cris de
vive l'empereur qu'il arrive au duomo la
cathédrale où l'on chante à tdf l'hôtel
de ville la première résidence de
napoléon il occupa l'appartement du
premier étage qui fut celui douze ans
plus tôt du chef de bataillon joseph
hugo et de son jeune fils victor hugo
ici durant près de trois semaines
l'empereur se transforma en architecte
prat sont les plans de sa future
résidence le palais des moulinets dans
cette auberge dont seul le nom a changé
les soldats de la garde venait trinquer
à la santé de napoléon sur le papier
l'empereur avait droit à 400 heures de
sa garde
le général cambronne lui en amena le
double
les chasseurs à pied de la vieille garde
le jet ici dans l'ancien couvent
saint-françois
juste de l'autre côté de la rue se
trouve la célèbre église de la
miséricorde où venait prier la mère de
napoléon qui avait tenu à rejoindre son
fils dans l'exil
l'endroit a traversé le temps sans
souffrir ici tous les ans le 5 mai jour
anniversaire de sa mort
une messe est célébrée à la mémoire de
l'empereur sur l'hôtel sont conservés
les reliques de saint christ 1 le patron
de la ville sur cette plaque de marbre
l'histoire de cette grosse couronne de
bois doré qui ornait le sommet de la
loge impériale du théâtre de
portoferraio vient ferrandini à 100
mètres de l'église la maison van tinh y
habiter père madame mère que napoléon y
soient venus ne fait aucun doute
fer de lance de l'armée de l'île d'elbe
les soldats de la vieille garde
venus de france et y en avait peu dont
l'empereur ne sut pas lé nom des hommes
qui laissent tomber le glaive pour le
piquer le ciseau
l'énergie impérial réveille les
helleboid les décrets pleuvent on
construit on aménage on cultive un
traces des routes toute l'île devient
une ruche bourdonnante
abriter entre le fort de l'étoile et
celui du faucon cette maison toute
simple c'est le palais impérial des
moulinets les tuileries de l'île d'elbe
et
au rez-de-chaussée du salon on passe
dans la bibliothèque
une bibliothèque riche d'un millier
d'ouvragés aux armes impérial provenant
de saint cloud de fontainebleau et de
compiègne
maintenant à la bibliothèque la modeste
chambre à coucher de napoléon
donnant sur le jardin la salle du
conseil et le bureau
al étage le grand salon pauline la soeur
de napoléon a régné ici de tous les
claques sa beauté elle rythmait la vie
de la cour des fêtes et des balles
qu'elle organisait son frère ne lui
demanda qu'une chose qu'elle évite les
soirs de réception de porter ses plus
beaux bijoux
il ne fallait pas froisser ces dames de
l'île d'elbe
le jardin l'italienne est toujours
surveillée par pauline immortalisé par
cette sculpture de canova pour le matin
napoléon aimait à s'y promener en tête à
tête avec son destin
l'île d'elbe c'est une poussière dans
pire pour l'homme qui a dicté sa loi de
moscou à madrid
à peine 224 kilomètres carrés pour 12000
habitants un royaume qu'il visite dans
ses moindres recoins et puisant son
entourage m'ont il est bien petit soupir
l empereur au coeur de l'île à l'ombre
du village de polio coule une source
une eau pure et fraîche qui désaltère à
napoléon
elle est aujourd'hui exploité et
commercialisé sous le nom de fontet
napoleone
sentinelle de pierre ce donjon veille
sur yon marina et ses mines de fer à
l'époque la principale richesse de l'île
le directeur des mines c'est pons de
l'hérault un homme droit républicain
dans l'âme sans aucun enthousiasme
vis-à-vis de l'empereur le 6 mai 1814
naples et on descend de cheval devant la
maison de pons de l'hérault pour
l'accueillir on a fleuri le jardin sans
penser à mal un parterre de fleurs de
lys mais voici le g à bonne enseigne dit
l'empereur en souriant
pons de l'hérault deviendra l'un des
fidèles
travers son lille pour rejoindre
marciana marina c'est le 1er septembre
1814 que m'arriver lesca et alexandre
son jeune fils débarque dans ce petit
port
alexandre c'est le fruit des amours de
napoléon et de la jolie polonaise
rencontrer à varsovie en 1807
là haut sur le monde tgv le mans jupiter
napoléon les attend
on
il a fait dresser sa tente de campagne
aux abords du sanctuaire de la madone
l'empereur a vécu ici deux jours
lumineux jouant avec son fils sous le
regard attendri de m'arriver lesca
mais le rêve a pris fin trop vite il a
dû se résigner à renvoyer la mère et
l'enfant
car et vous pour croire que sa femme
l'impératrice marie-louise et le petit
roi de rome allait venir le rejoindre
une illusion jamais il ne les revit
le chemin qui passe devant l'ermitage
conduit au sommet constellé de rochers
qui semble avoir été jetés ici par les
dieux en colère napoléon ya passé de
longues heures
observant la corse qui par beau temps se
détache sur l'horizon porto longo n'est
aujourd'hui porto 1-0 après le départ de
la comtesse valech qu'à naples et on
s'installe dans la citadelle qui domine
ce village une citadelle devenu par
décret palais impérial encerclé par la
verdure
l'endroit est aujourd'hui sous la coupe
des militaires à quelques kilomètres de
là niché dans un paysage grandiose
l'ermitage notre-dame-de-monts cerrato
un cadre enchanteur
si loin d amertume de la vie murmura
l'empereur envers et contre tout il sait
que son étoile ne l'a pas abandonné
il sait qu'en france on le regrette
chaque jour un peu plus il sait aussi
que l'europe veut en finir avec lui déjà
on parle de l'exilé à sainte hélène
dans le golfe de prochain pauline la
soeur préférée de napoléon et mettent à
se baigner nue avec le soleil pour
témoin cet îlot rocheux porte son nom
pauline au grand coeur qui n'hésita pas
à vendre ses diamants pour permettre à
napoléon d'acquérir sa maison de san
martino à quelques kilomètres de porto
ferraille au cet édifice imposant
n'existait pas c'est le prince des mid
of son neveu par alliance qui le fit
construire en 1851
aujourd'hui ce palais sert d'écrin à des
manifestations culturelles
sur le toit du palais le saint claud de
l'île d'elbe la petite maison de san
martino
de sa chambre il pouvait passer dans son
cabinet de travail ou dans sa salle de
bain
comme par magie le temps à épargner les
décors
la salle des pyramides servait de salle
à manger c'est le joyau de cette demeure
on devine sans mal quels souvenirs de
jeunesse
elle rappelait à l'empereur et à ses
compagnons
aujourd'hui encore le drapeau de
l'empereur flotte sur portoferraio le 26
février 1815 napoléon et sa garde
quittent l'île d'elbe pour reprendre le
chemin de la gloire
l'aigle va voler de clocher en clocher
jusqu'à paris
la cote de france n'est plus qu'un trait
un trait entre ciel et mer
ce 12 juillet 1815 napoléon quitte la
frégate la salle où il vit depuis son
départ de rochefort il débarque à l'île
d'aix
aux cris de vive l'empereur tous les
habitants la classe
napoléon va passer trois jours sur cette
petite île qui défend l'embouchure de la
charente trois jours en france
les derniers sur cette terre française
qu'il a tant aimée trois jours
d'hésitations et de doutes sur le parti
à prendre on échafaude des plans pour
échapper à la croisière anglaise qui
rôdent guettant un point
trois jours fatale qui ont marqués lille
à jamais
c'est dans cette maison aujourd'hui un
musée grâce à la famille gourgaud que
tout va se jouer
tous se disputent l'honneur de sauver
l'empereur et de le conduire en amérique
joseph son frère imagine même de se
livrer aux anglais en se faisant passer
pour napoléon
ému l'empereur lembras et refuse il
refusera toutes les propositions
en fait
sa résolution est prise
et dans la nuit du 13 au 14 juillet il
écrit ou prince régent l'angleterre
napoléon scelle son destin ici dans
cette petite chambre qu'il occupe à
trois jours durant
la pendule s'est figé dans le temps
comme toutes celles de ce musée elles
marquent leur de la mort de l'empereur
à la lumière d'une chandelle napoléon
écrit en butte aux factions qui divise
mon pays et à l'inimitié des plus
grandes puissances de l'europe
j'ai terminé ma carrière politique et je
viens comme thémistocle m'asseoir au
foyer du peuple britannique
je veux mais sous la protection de ses
lois que je réclame de votre altesse
royale comme du plus puissant du plus
constant et du plus généreux de mes
ennemis
oui
au pied de son balcon cet arbre qu'il a
plantés en 1808 lors de son premier
séjour à l'île d'aix
le temps des jours heureux
suite
napoléon a choisi cette chambre car de
son balcon
ils pouvaient surveiller les allées et
venues des bateaux anglais
le 15 juillet 1815 il va se livrer il
revêt l'uniforme des chasseurs de la
garde et se coiffe du petit chapeau
d'ici il quitte le sol de france
le général becker lui demande votre
majesté désir telle que je la compagne
jusqu'à la croisière non général becker
il ne faut pas que l'on dise que la
france m'a livré aux anglais
l'empereur n'a bien sûr pas vu le fort
boyard même si l'un ordonné la
construction
l'ouvragé a été terminé bien après sa
mort et c'est aux cris de vive
l'empereur qu'il va monter à bord du
bellérophon
cette bastide et maire sorti des flots
cette forteresse de basalte noir c'est
sainte hélène vision terrible c'est
exactement celle qu'a eue l'empereur le
15 octobre 1815 après 67 jours de mer
à l'aide de sa lorgnette il inspecte cet
amoncellement de roches et et sans dire
un mot regagne sa cabine pour travailler
avec las cases
quelques minutes plus tard il grommela
ce n'est pas un beau séjour
j'aurais mieux fait de rester en egypte
je serai à présent empereur de tout
l'orient
aujourd'hui sainte hélène est toujours
aussi éloigné du reste du monde
il n'y a pas d'aéroport partent en
angleterre il faut quinze jours de mer
pour y arriver
le synthé l'ena passe ici toutes les dix
semaines les cales surchargé
lille ne produisons rien l'angleterre se
doit de tout importer
et
il fait déjà nuit lorsque l'empereur
débarque en gravissant les marches
taillées dans le roc démarche depuis
longtemps à l'abandon
aujourd'hui on rejoint toujours la terre
ferme en chaloupe et toute l'île et sur
lequel pour vous accueillir
le passage du synthé l'ena est la seule
distraction de ces gens
six mille personnes vivent dans cette
prison sans barreaux la moitié habite
gemstone sebourg être anglais entre deux
falaises
l'empereur a passé sa première nuit à
porter ou south la maison se dressait
ici à la place de ce parking de quart
le fidèle marchand premier va les
chambres de l'empereur raconte dans ses
mémoires que l'ensemble de la petite
ville composée d'une centaine de maisons
est propre et coke
cela n'a pas changé si ce n'est le
nombre des maisons
le commissaire de louis xviii le stupide
m'ont soutenu napoléon l'appeler ainsi
habité cette demeure
on
le 20 octobre 1815 l'empereur s'installe
pour six semaines au brouillard
un modeste pavillon que monsieur
balcombe riche négociant coloniale a
fait construire pour donner des goûters
aux enfants il va y passer ce que l'on
est tenté d'appeler les jours roses de
la captivité
entouré de la sympathie de ses hôtes de
l'espièglerie de miss betsy et des soins
de las cases
nous
les briards sont au pied du fort de hand
qui tous les soirs annonce aux canaux
l'heure du couvre-feu
oh
l'empereur a parcouru ces collines
jusqu'à cette chute d'eau un coin dont
il aimait la fraîcheur
partant de james tonnes cette route à
flanc de montagne
mon talon good la maison napoléon ou
plutôt sa prison avant d'y arriver
on passe par huguette napoléon y est
venu souvent rendre visite au grand
maréchal bertrand dont la première
maison était à cet emplacement le
plateau de longwood constamment battue
par les vents et fouettées par la pluie
le plus mauvais endroit de l'île
ici on passe en france l'ong hood et la
vallée de la tombe
en tout une vingtaine d'hectares acheté
par napoléon iii à la reine victoria en
aujourd'hui propriété de l'état français
ici dans le petit pavillon chinois à
l'abri des regards indiscrets
napoléon a passé des heures à observer
les bateaux en 1819
il a fait aménager ces jardins pour
tromper l'ennui le bac à la forme de son
chapeau tout comme la grotte une idée du
grand maréchal bertrand
il a dirigé la construction de ces
jardins comme on commande sur un champ
de bataille
le jardin d'alice celui de marchands
celui des neuf et rase tous ont été mis
à contribution
c'est aller baptisé l'allée de bertrand
mène à la deuxième maison du grand
maréchal et sa famille elle a perdu un
étage
c'est à peu près là vu que napoléon a pu
contempler pendant six interminables
années
derrière longwood les communs où
vivaient montholon et les siens ainsi
que le général gourgaud c'est
aujourd'hui la résidence du consul de
france
à quelques mètres de la maison l'arbre
préféré de l'empereur sous ces
feuillages
il aimait à lire et à rêver
je
dans ce volet fermé napoléon a fait des
coupes et deux en poche pour lui
permettre d'observer à l'aide de sa
longue vue qui arrivait sur son domaine
sur ce billard original l'empereur
déplié ses cartes et les mains dans le
dos arpenter la pièce en dictant ses
mémoires
sur cette mappemonde d'un doigt rageur
il a effacé le nom de sainte hélène
c'est ici dans le salon exactement à cet
emplacement que l'empereur napoléon a
rendu son dernier souffle
avec un peu d'imagination on peut encore
entendre le bruit de ses pas
on
quittons la salle à manger pour son
intérieur
là ces nuits ont été plus longues que
ses jours quelques mètres carrés pour
l'homme habitué aux plus beaux palais
d'europe
l'empereur a perdu la faculté de
commander au sommeil
réfugié dans ses souvenirs il passait
d'un de ces lits de camp à l'autre à la
recherche du repos
et
les anglais lui ont offert la seule
chose qui manquait à sa gloire la
fortune
de la salle de bain on passe à la petite
chambre de marchands dont napoléon dira
les services qu'il m'a rendu sont ceux
d'un ami voilà ce qu'est devenu l'ong
hood après la mort de l'empereur
voilà ce que les anglais en ont fait une
ferme à brienne sur son cahier d'écolier
bonaparte écrivait sainte-hélène
petite-ile il ne s'était pas trompé à
peine la taille de paris
c'est un 18 août au xvième siècle jour
de la sainte hélène que lille a été
découverte à plantation house rien n'a
changé si ce n'est le nom du gouverneur
le 4 octobre 1820 napoléon arrive à
sandy bay des heures à cheval qui l'ont
épuisée
il demande l'hospitalité à monsieur
diouf tonnes dans cette maison
cela sera sa dernière promenade
au cours des rares sorties de sa maison
prison l'empereur et sa suite étaient
toujours observées au loin par des
officiers anglais
des milliers de soldats étaient chargés
de sa surveillance
au fond de la vallée du pêcheur surnommé
par les français valériane aph vivait
une très jolie jeune fille boutons de
rose
sa maison est aujourd'hui une ruine
l'empereur est aussi venu ici à flanc de
colline dans la maison de miss manson
l'excentrique de lille qui parlait cru
et monte en amazone un boeuf dressé
c'est par ce chemin redécouvert par
michel martineau le consul de france que
napoléon est descendu au fond de cette
vallée appelé le bol à punch du diable
c'est ici au pied de la source qu'il a
décidé de se faire enterrer et le 5 mai
1821 s'envole le plus puissant souffle
de vie qui jamais animal argile humaine
si depuis longtemps le sol qui abritait
la tombe n'est plus victime de la
ferveur des pèlerins
cet arbre lui a tout vu
et
qui
il
ce sont les soldats anglais qui ont
creusé ce chemin pour permettre de
descendre le lourd cercueil de
l'empereur
ultime mesquinerie anglaise la pierre
tombale est nu elle ne porte aucune
inscription
les anglais n'ont pas voulu que l'on
grave simplement le nom de napoléon
parce qu'il ne lui reconnaissait pas son
titre d'empereur
j'ai porté la couronne impériale de
france la couronne de faire de l'italie
et maintenant l'angleterre en a donné
une autre plus grande encore et plus
glorieuse celle portée par le sauveur du
monde
une couronne d'épinés
oui
on
non
oh
e.on
m